a food bank in east London
one that on the surface looks like any
of the thousands running across the UK
but this one is different it caters
solely to people with no recourse to
public funds a Visa condition that means
they have no access to the welfare state
an absent that safety net the cost of
living crisis looms even larger being a
mother I feel very upset because I have
to choose from anyone building a heating
or putting a foot in the plate so I have
to put a heating on and compromise the
meal instead of giving him a three meals
a day we need to compromise for a one
snack and a one meal or two meal
CEO Elias tells me the use of his
service has more than doubled in the
last few months alone it's heartbreaking
they don't get any help from the
government they're on their own and many
of them they do they are working many of
them have two jobs but even then they're
not able to afford you know the normal
day-to-day expenses
there are around one and a half million
people living in the UK with no recourse
to public funds it means no access to
vital benefits like Universal Credit
child benefit and some cost of living
support schemes in theory if people face
real hardship there is a mechanism known
as a change of conditions application
that can allow people to access much
needed support but that process can take
time a luxury that many simply don't
have
people like this young mother who spoke
to me only on condition of anonymity she
and her daughter recently became
homeless whilst awaiting a change of
conditions decision her daughter is a
British citizen but as child benefit is
claimed by the parent not the child she
is ineligible
it makes you feel like almost useless
like you can't provide for your child
you kind of have nowhere to turn to you
call different organizations for help
and it all comes down to you need a
change of condition but you can't get
the help you need right away and getting
a change of condition is not something
that happens overnight one organization
that helps people in similar situations
says the system needs to change
the average amount of time the
application takes to decide is six weeks
which is a huge amount of time for
somebody to be waiting but we've seen
applications take months and even over a
year to decide it means that people have
to go through a very long and grueling
application process before they can
access the most basic support
but some of these concerns to the home
office they told us the provision of no
recourse to public funds has been upheld
by successive governments and maintains
that those coming to the UK should do so
on a basis that prevents burdens on the
taxpayer
so far the government has resisted calls
from Charities and from a cross-party
committee of MPS for reform until those
calls are heated people with no recourse
to public funds will continue to feel
left out in the cold Matthew Thompson
Sky News